nos piden nombrar un ángulo adyacente al
ángulo bgd al ángulo b
es decir a este de acá bueno pues un
ángulo adyacente a otro es uno que
comparta alguno de los dos rayos con el
ángulo con el que empezamos por ejemplo
aquí el ángulo je veux comparte el rayo
jefe con el vejete entonces uno de los
ángulos adyacentes al ángulo bgd es el
ángulo el ángulo bg a b
que también podríamos haberlo nombrado
como agm es lo mismo sale vamos a ver
qué otros hay por ejemplo el fcb también
es adyacente porque también comparte el
rayo jefe entonces también tendríamos el
fcb el ángulo
efe
del otro lado tendríamos por ejemplo al
de g
porque comparte el rayo head entonces
tendríamos el ángulo de g
y también tendríamos por ejemplo el cg
de el ángulo cgd me parece que hay otros
más pero vamos a poner estos cuatro
estos cuatro son suficientes el cg de
sale bueno ahora vamos a la segunda
parte dice me nombra un ángulo opuesto
por el vértice con el ángulo egea el
ángulo
es decir este ángulo de acá bueno pues
para pensar en ángulos opuestos por el
vértice lo que hacemos es trazar dos
rectas dos rectas así siguen
indefinidamente hacia allá hacia allá
hacia allá y estas dos rectas podemos
pensar que hacen cuatro ángulos o bien
dos parejas de ángulos opuestos por el
vértice donde este ángulo de acá este
ángulo de acá es opuesto por el vértice
con este de acá y éste acá es opuesto
por el vértice con este de acá y resulta
que miden lo mismo pero después
practicaremos de esas cosas entonces en
la figura de acá lo que tenemos que
hacer es identificar qué rectas forman
al ángulo
y sería esta de acá la egb la egb y la
dga la deje
y entonces forman estos cuatro ángulos
sale este el eje el agv el bcd y el de g
y el ángulo que no es adyacente al a que
es el eje de que es el que ya está
marcado en color rosa vale entonces aquí
el ángulo el ángulo que podemos nombrar
es el ángulo bg de ángulo b g de o bien
dgb vale bueno vamos a la parte número 3
dice nombra un ángulo que forman una
pareja alineada con el ángulo de gf el
ángulo de gf este de acá de g
efe sale déjame marcarlo en color rojo
es este de acá y para que un ángulo
forme una pareja alineada con éste
tenemos que encontrar un ángulo
adyacente pero que además forme una
línea una línea recta con el df por
ejemplo si nos vamos de este lado
al ángulo fg a el fg a que voy a marcar
por acá es uno de los que forman una
pareja alineada
efe que a una pareja alineada con de gf
pero hay otro del otro lado verdad el
ángulo de gc este acá porque completa la
recta c efe
sale entonces otro que funciona es el
ángulo de hesse de gs bueno vamos al
último a ver qué dice el último dice
nombra un ángulo opuesto por el vértice
con el ángulo efe gv
efe gv sería efe gv este de acá lo voy a
marcar así en azul
en azul entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es pues ver de dónde viene este
ángulo de que dos rectas y resulta que
viene de estas dos de esta de acá que
voy a pintar en verde y destaca que voy
a pintar también en verde entonces
tenemos esas dos líneas rectas y el
ángulo opuesto por el vértice sería el
de este lado que sería el cg en este de
acá este de acá y los otros dos ángulos
son simplemente ángulos adyacentes al
vejez
efe sale entonces el que es opuesto por
el vértice este vértice de acá sería el
ángulo cg y el ángulo c
o bien el ángulo g c